yeah welcome to this video covering
magnus carlsen's game some at the second
day of the rapid world championships in
Astana Kazakhstan Magnus started with
four and a half out of five from
yesterday on saturday on friday i'm
sorry on the first day of the tournament
and today the second day also five games
and this video will feature a four of
these games because one video already
done by Mia featured the game that he
won against Chakri arm Mammadyarov I'm i
did a la sort of live video on this 50
minutes and yeah really AM recommend
this one for great end game okay so
let's get going here the sixth round of
the tournament um he played them Alex
Adria from dre of playing black cards
and white and Magnus open deform Dre
events for the caro-kann which he often
plays his sort of mixes it between the
the caro-kann if he wants to yeah stay
solid and the Sicilian if he wants to go
for win so against cars in here you go
he went for the safe path yeah cousin
I'm going here for the two nights
variation an old favorite of bobby
fischer's I think this variation never
had um yeah a very fearsome reputation
for black but did yeah sort of yeah fits
in with Carlton style of choosing not so
I'm so well-trodden path so the same so
Bishop g4 which is normal age three and
now e6 I met him Magnus comes up with
slide surprise I think white um usually
in this kind of position place a move
like g3 or even
g3 which is a normal kind of development
in those kind of positions um but cards
in here 24 which is less common I'm
black now captured yeah and Queen takes
d4 I think Knight takes e4 Queen takes
d4 it's very questionable if you have
enough compensation there White has some
development but it's a central pawn so
he went with queenie form yeah Knight f6
gaining a temple and Queen to h4 yeah
sort of the only Square to cover the
default born and Queen a5 know which is
interesting an interesting move um black
immediately tries to get some counter
play on this diagonal here possibly with
Bishop b4 95 stuff like this and white
plays Bishop d3 and 9 a-6 interesting
the idea to immediately grab this
important Bishop and if white white
played castles now if Y term would have
played them slug a 3 here black still
can do this as some there's a pin
working hmm now that I think of it maybe
this is something white could actually
consider here castle now Black's Queen
doesn't have a square and
black would take here there's this this
cute move hmm interesting so maybe wide
could have considered to to play a three
but ok black is not forced to play a
night before immediately ok let's look
what happened to he castles and allowed
this move rook the one to cover d3 make
sense otherwise White's pawn structure
would get destroyed cannot move the
bishop of course because simply the
spawn of saying so not much choice
rookie one we should be seven yeah
emphasizing that this queen is not in
the greatest diagonal white um took care
of that and now black castle Queen side
so I'm also quickly giving this rook
some use on d 8 a-3 white couldn't stand
this any longer and clarified the
position age six ya well what what what
can I do taking us some also not great
black has a play on d4 and this is quite
a silly piece on c3 so I'm Magnus played
Bishop t2 maybe intending at some point
to to move the night and black now Queen
f5 so let's take stock of this position
um young white um didn't get anything
out of the opening black has a very
solid position perfect porn structure no
weaknesses at all and this is play on
deform and white um
down as a somewhat clumsy knight on c3
and all these pieces are not doing much
so um this sum is obviously a successful
black this kind of position but it's not
like like as an advantage he looks
uncomfortable but it's nothing special
yet so rookie one ship here to activate
a bit and 94 so we get this
simplification now one night hey I
exchanged but Carlton didn't play
Queenie for make it totally easy still
wanted to to try a bit here maybe but
queensgate exchange anyway yeah and this
is some an endgame we're even Magnus
cannot do something yeah black was sort
of threatening c5 so this blocking move
and you see that black has nothing to
fear Him as white doesn't have any
meaningful porn breaks like it's very
strong on this d five points so any
ideas like this to open it up are pretty
much unrealistic and from a structured
point of view black has the better
bishop here as his pawns on white
squares and if you look at the d2 bishop
white has quite a number of points on
dark squares so um there's simply not
nothing to play for here from White's
point of view and we see that the
position closes up further and there's
pretty much nothing happening in this
game yeah black is drawing a bit here he
certainly somewhat slightly better but
it's maybe nothing serious yet
yeah pretty much nothing going on here
so now black maybe intends to play rook
d to a 8 and 2 a 2 and this could get
ugly aha not quite sure why it didn't
didn't try that at least yeah some
maneuvering going on I mean black is
also perfectly content with the draw you
need to look at the times also they were
both pretty free down on time so like to
the CZ moves ok now nadja form
interesting to get some activity for the
rook and now why term gets his g for
porn back of course covering c3 Ops III
don't want to give up that and we have
repetition of the position and game
drawn now it's so pretty yeah a dull
game um well they're Magnus's some quite
simplistic opening ups opening a choice
not quite sure what's happening here I
can you two have I hit the wrong button
well why it's very simplistic opening
choice led to very dry position once so
this Bishop 23 is gone there's simply
nothing to play for and they continued
but basically it was a draw all along so
I draw here second game of today I need
to check don't have it was against Boris
Gelfand Magnus playing black and
girlfriend opened g4
and we got a Queens gambit declined the
classical d classical opening that black
and choose against deform and super
solid and the kind of line you can learn
and still play in 50 years okay so very
solid stuff but now a slight surprise
from Magnus he played b6 the current
main line here is not be to d7 and this
is a line which has been played from
blacks point of view by all leading top
players of today Kramnik Anand aronian
everybody basically very solid um a bit
down I'm Magnus went b6 which is usually
a bit more fighting but we see that here
after after c5 girl phone decided to
play a very safe move here which
nevertheless led to some advantage he
captured on c5 wife of white also could
have thought about moves like this year
to keep a bit more tension in the
position let's say takes and then let's
say rook look here trying to play an
isolated pawn position not not at all
out of the questions kind of
continuation but he decided to take c5
and after this we see that the pawn
structure is almost completely
symmetrical so we've got those C and D
lines open very common to position type
in the Queens gambit but there is some
difference in the position of both sides
Black has this Bishop on b7 which is a
nice piece covering the diagonal but
this
six move also involves some weakening
here and the issue answer is if you look
at the development young white plays
Knight b5 um white simply has got more
pieces out this be 89 to sell at home
and white already has a rook on the D
file so why does certainly better here
the only question is if black can
equalize this sort of trade down enough
stuff to get a draw or I've white get
will get something substantial here so
not the huge successor opening wise for
magnesium needs to really defend ninety
seven and 96 directly trying for
something here white had some
alternatives of course you could also go
here or often this kind of maneuver is
also an idea to kick this Bishop away so
multiple possibilities but 96 is quite
logical to take use of the development
advantage I'm black now when to Bishop
g5 alternative would be Bishop c6 but I
think he doesn't like all this bishops
in the C file after after Roxy one so uh
ship d5 was played and now be should be
5 and this some tries to use this this
somewhat crowded piece configuration
here on in the center but Magnus played
this amazing move Knight h5 very
concrete way to approach the position
the amazing thing is if you look at this
what what what else should black play
let's say black would play a muffler
group dat are just enormous
what could white try then yeah it's
still not easy he didn't need to play
night age five I think don't see a
really great continuation here white
looks somewhat better but it's not
obvious how he should continue this move
may be may be here and now if you take
you can just take with the rook end
cover f7 yeah I mean night h5 wasn't the
only move but very very concrete one
this is say this is no hanging but black
is also threatening to take here and
take on d 60 quite a technical solution
why it took and black took here and now
night to be five if white wood would
actually grab this night then Bishop b6
we detect the spawn white cannot I can
he could play I played this
theoretically I 158 very good for black
but what I was getting to is this move
was quite a funny line leading to a
completely rectified pawn structure so
there are some ways here for why to UM
to go wrong slightly I mean this rook
endgame wasn't may be so terrible but
night be five is better I guess still
this night is hanging and what should
like do if he would let's say we treat
the night to g6 then there's a smooth so
I'm not too attractive you played rook
d8 sort of asking the bishop okay where
do you go now
and now white grabbed route 27 I've got
a funny position now with two nights
against two bishops but this nights are
just very active and push this these
bishops around especially this Bishop
doesn't have a good square so like at
Aksum the 59 with f6 night back to d3 no
other square I guess so wyd ensures that
you will get one one of those bishops
which happened now and now we've
transposed into an endgame where why
does vary slightly better maybe yeah I
guess so white structure is better but
black should be able to hold it so r up
to six attacking these two I'm black
just just render oxy aid because okay
this pawn is also hanging so I'm sorry
if rube takes e6 black could take btooom
so this isn't isn't a great one so wyd
um protected to be porn by simply
pushing it to be three King out seven to
use the king and this is an important
feature here blacks king is it's just
quicker in helping in the battle here
yeah covering e6 and now wide uses the
night king is seven rugae six and rook
c7 so why does putting some pressure on
these these pawns and black tries to get
rid of the weaknesses by pushing 95 yeah
and now it just a very concrete position
e six and b7 attacked so black move the
rock
and now I'd grab the porn here so at
first sight you think okay White has
succeeded here winning upon but now very
very nice move Bishop c8 and this show
this shows that this night is nicely
positioned but once it it is moving the
c-4 porn is lost the elfin played night
a for here just to show what happens if
white plays the sort of zero move let's
say here then black would go to c6 and
to grab this pawn and here wyd already
needs to be a little bit yeah needs to
be a little bit of cab needs to be
careful in a bit here because um yeah
potentially this night this Bishop can
be very strong be 75 and this night
doesn't have an outpost it's still a
draw sure but nothing why should be
aiming for so he went night a form and
now look B form this may be and not so
accurate but ok it's a rapid game black
had a minute and so on here Magnus also
could have played rugae 6 and this is
maybe a the clearest way to secure draw
white needs to take here and then this
move attacking the pawn and this night
is just yeah a bit of a silly PCM let's
say why to protect the pawn then black
and just the tech here and regain his
pawn and it's a dead wrong so this would
have drawn immediately he went looked to
be 493 and now you see that yeah
he this 95 was threatened so black
needed to go to evade remove the motor a
king and now there's a double attack
here so after the smoke clears am white
ends up with a with a rook endgame upon
up the only black like help here is to
get count to play on the second rank so
let's see he first grab this pawn g3
rook air-five and rugby one good move to
go to be seven we should look briefly
what happens if white takes on e six
then rook c1 check and rooks assume this
is a very important um tactical point
here as f2 is yeah not coverable by any
square over any any piece have to gets
lost and this is also close to a
perpetual if like it gets to take this
with the rook so rook takes c6 um
doesn't help this is why when droopy one
no h5 securing the the rook here and
white one edge form at this point white
could have thought about thought about
this move the problem here is that this
counter play idea now just fails to
checkmate so the question is what what
would would have happened after him oops
hit the wrong button there what would
have happened after this move I think
black is in serious trouble here not
quite sure I could try to cover this
pawn then white can start to push the
ape
and it's really questionable a firm
black can hold us to looks on the 7th I
usually very very good so this route b7
move would have been very important i
guess and gave right quite serious
winning chances you played a page for
though preventing g5 end and moves like
this and now King g8 very important move
because now what we see here were now
white played this and after check Roxy
too we have the mansion counter play on
f2 and now this kind of move is no
checkmate this is a problem with the
King on f8 this was made but here it's
just nothing even possibly a bed for
wide so in this position is white grab
g7 and it ended up in a perpetual one of
either white or black are giving a
perpetual on the second rank so Magnus
was in a bit of trouble in this game
after he missed the clear draw here with
with rookie six and here here rook to
rook one to be seven would have been
very critical for black if white would
have played this very very tough to
defend so a bit of luck here next game
um I think your cards and played
Mammadyarov this is what I already
covered in the separate live video so we
can go straight to the fourth game of
today um console playing black again and
he's playing a Grand Master Card chef
from France yeah disguiser with a bit
infamous for this incident at the
tournament in India way showed up
yeah so drunk to a game that he actually
fell off his chair if I'm not mistaken
he really fell off his chair they had to
carry him out of the hole yeah but I
think if he really is not completely
drunk from the day before he's a very
strong Grandmaster 2600 something and he
certainly gave his best here okay
neither 3d 5ft four and we have a sloth
defense so it didn't want to go for this
Queens gambit declined again and that
card she have also plays the Catalan I
think ok I've got III Bishop f5 this
line we already saw yesterday with them
Magnus playing wide actually against
bootle gone but here the current GF
decides to capture on d5 which is not
the main move man move smiles is 36
night h 4 and so on but see txt 5 is
also a possibility she takes d5 queen
bee three and this is some bit of a
forgotten line I actually played this
myself a couple of times as wide and at
first sight it looks really yeah a bit
strange because you exchange on d5 you
still have this somewhat bad bishop and
see one you don't have it on f4 like in
the exchange Slav but one point is this
queen bee three simply attacks b7 I
black leads to attend to this he covered
with Quincy seven Bishop d to e six
check here and now Magnus played night
be to the sandwiches a bit of a rare
move it's it's not the main move the
main move here is knight c6 after which
white can play he doesn't need to we can
also castle but white can play this move
and this
one idea of this kind of some kind of
line with CT xt5 Bishop t2 you want to
get rid of this somewhat bad bishop p.m.
and hope to get to a position where at
the end white would take on c6 and after
b.tech c6 you would pressurize like I'm
on this pawn I'd show just one sample
line which is quite um yeah and it's not
good for blog editor just to show what
why does after he wants to have this
kind of position and this is arguably
quite quite nice for white ok so this
didn't happen as Magnus played on this
jacket ignite be 27 and I'm absolutely
not sure what white should do now I mean
I played this line but I simply forgot
what what might be good here white
castle and now a six note that this move
which looks quite nice at first sight
this answered by roxy one and this pin
here is quite quite annoying this kind
of stuff would be terrible for black ok
so Bishop c2 is not a good move a six
rook c1 gaining a temple and Queen B 6
yeah now white of course has to do
something about this bishop he retreated
to e 2 i'm an alternative here would
have been Bishop d7
this kind of line it's something that
needs to be checked wyd enters on the
seventh but black can play this simple
move here and now it's questionable what
what this really has accomplished we
should be six is coming and then the
rookwood need to retreat so at the end
term this is most likely just better for
black so one this is why he he played
Bishop to e2 yeah Magnus exchanged here
and played Bishop to b6 so how to assess
this position yeah black certainly
doesn't have any problems here but it
still looks fairly solid for white he
shouldn't be in huge trouble here 93
with the idea to yeah maybe this is a
simple idea using the pinion of the pawn
but one idea also could be two to get an
i2c five which would be nice of course
King e7 prevents any night be five
tricks and now he went night to h4
threatening to take so a retreat here
and night a for this was a bit
surprising to me to play this at this
point I was more expecting why to take
and play h3 some something like this and
now Bishop to h5 which is quite quite an
interesting what wyd retreated but what
we should look at is what happens if I
mean white doesn't really want to
exchange you know because it helps to
have those bishops off and white surface
bit from from this this piece it's still
not terrible but you really don't want
to do that I mean white white has moves
like this here and like it's a bit tied
down to this pawn this isn't so so awful
for white but you you don't want to play
this capturing on age five so the
question is we played this but what
about this move here black and actually
think about this move attacking the
night and now maybe even gaining more
space white cannot go to e5 which is a
real shame something like this year yeah
and this is a sort of position where
it's may be equal but yeah black has
accomplished a little bit here gaining
some space on the King side and maybe a
little bit to play form so i think this
is why he decided to just retreat the
night but this is certainly nothing that
black minded threatening now to win a
piece on d to as the night is pinned so
we needed to move the bishop yeah and
now be five sort of asking why it's okay
what is your night doing there you would
like to go here but it's yeah it's
simply bluntness a pawn so wyd um at the
end decided to retreat and yeah if you
look at this wide simply made a couple
of moves with his knights night age for
a four and so on and didn't didn't trick
didn't really make any progress well
black has gained some space he played
before now yeah night all the way back
to be one of course you could think
about this move but the thing is this
night doesn't have any square it cannot
retreat because of the poor
on and all this is very nicely covered
so you might face a pretty ugly position
where this night doesn't have a square
this is some way you retreated here he
at least has got to the idea to activate
the night on g2 okay like covering the
before porn you should be five yeah he
wanted to get rid of the pin out so I
think rook c8 quite an interesting move
in this situation oops over this was bad
hit the wrong button there oh no I went
all the way back sorry let's get to the
position rook c8 white now played night
to d2 you also of course need to check
this kind of line which looks a bit
crazy at first from White I mean because
this looks super ugly but it continues
rook a seven would be 137 king of six
and now king of one rupee tomb yeah I
think what might have calculated to this
point and it looks very scary I checked
this briefly with the computer and it
says the red gifts that quite typical
000 so maybe this was what white should
have played but it's hard to imagine to
to go for this in a rapid game because
you can easily be lost if you
miscalculate so night BTW to is normal
and soul it's not nothing not so much
happening black is comfortable but it's
it's not like white is some yeah why
does close to lost or something it's
still playable position
exchange now rook b8 bishop f1 bishop g6
so not much happening here really f3
just the normal kind of moves to
strengthen the position this f3 move
might prepare bishop g3 also allow the
king to participate and now Magnus 25
really showing that he is willing to to
try something in the position one point
is that if white takes here we should be
five is a bit annoying sb2 it's a
weakness white cannot really cover this
pawn you would need to try to drum up
some counter play with rook a6 c6 to a
sick stuff like that but nothing you
really want to play so wide plate Misha
p.m. like we capture captured on d4 and
now night f8 this is a good maneuver the
night on d7 really wasn't doing much and
he wants to bring it to you 6 putting
pressure on the d4 pawn and this is a
problem here for why this default porn
cannot easily be defended with a night
because the night is in a really silly
position here his own pieces block all
the possible squares and this phone is
cause for concern on D form King f2 he
wants to use the King to protect it and
now f5 yeah you see that black is
constantly going for threats here
threatening f4 gaining some space so why
does under a little bit of pressure here
it's not like his loss but he always
needs to defend took and therefore
closing up the position at first you
would think okay this is a bad bishop
but this isn't the case at all
cause it can go to age five and control
this very important f3 square so that
the night cannot go to a 3 without
getting exchanged and wide also cannot
go here because it would simply blend up
on so this Bishop IAM is some quite
useful Bishop d3 g6 just strengthening
everything a bit and now g5 yeah still
keeping the pressure doing yeah playing
active moves which falls wide to defend
accurately he took and therefore this
was the idea this little tactical trick
here and now black actually has a choice
he took on G Phi which is so yes
certainly an ok move he also could have
thought about taking on deform would be
interesting let's say 92 to cover here
and then Bishop g6 this also looks like
like a somewhat better because he's got
a very nice nicely coordinate position
night and pawn prevent White's King from
getting active and this night always
takes me three so tiny white down this
would have been a very serious
alternative he played 90 92 covering
e-form e6 you see the pressure and how
does why protect it now he can't he
needs to take on age seven problem is as
I mentioned it once you go here like
just captures and wins this pawn and
even this one so
some i think is already losing so um
yeah why decided to give up the d4 pawn
and capture age 7 but now black is very
active the knight on d4 is super strong
and luke h8 trying to do something on
the h-bomb yeah if I was hanging so if
you look at the whole can of way out
this game preceded you see that black
always operated with small threats here
and there and made a little bit of
progress now he's got this pawn on on
the default and possible weaknesses to
attack why this is the very solid but he
had to defend all the time so I'm very
thankless task h3 securing this this
opponent also Nigel's possibility rook
c8 it's getting very concrete now with
this Roxy to idea we should be too yeah
wants to exchange some some pieces to
release some pressure and the rook
enters
what are some alternative hmm yeah white
could have played maybe King you one
yeah it's just an ugly position Black is
pressing and pressing if white would
take here hmm maybe this kind of stuff
and this is also not fun to play note
this neat little thing here nice mate
okay yeah why this is constantly under
pressure so I have this checkmate issue
again if it's checkmate somehow my back
button doesn't work really cool not
quite sure why okay we're back in the
main position you have somehow softest
this issue not quite sure what what's
happening there needed to restart this
this whole thing okay um it doesn't like
checkmates this program no idea what's
happening so I'm i was looking at this
move kingi one but in the game I think
maybe this is tougher then then what was
what was played in the game the game to
cart sheffer took on one age five rookie
to King moves Andruw captured yeah and
now this this deep on is super strong
white protected be three yeah I'm Plex
Luke on the seventh so it's also not bad
oh here it's the second rang
yeah King e6 both the players down to
one minute here black actually had a
good alternative in a form which is
quite strong the ideas of white takes
here then night c4 is a very strong move
with this idea and also you've got the
beep on running I think this is somewhat
stronger than King e6 but it's easy to
say after the game black still keeps a a
big advantage here h5 and team runs over
with the King to take care about the
edge porn yeah now pushing the the deep
on
yeah why this is really lost here this
deep one is just as strong and in
cooperation with the f porn and the
night night only five yeah I like to
emphasize that bishops are stronger than
Knights very often this is really the
case but this is really a poor bishop
and a monster night only 50 game yeah
very so very sorry PCM white goes here
you can play him and black just just
wins wins easily yeah so one of those
technical wins again like let's say in
this this kind of position being very
slightly better and he grinds on and on
setting setting problems for for the
opponent and then it's breakdown after a
while okay so on need win and yeah the
final game of this event was some
against um yeah Sega coyoacán who also
is having a super great outstanding
tournament he won also lots of lots of
games and was in the lead together with
cards and I think before the round or
they were very close and you know Magnus
was on plus six already winning six
games and just drawing three I guess
cause Kaela's so let's see what happened
and in this match of the two leaders of
the tournament you form e 5 we got the
Berlin born in defense to the ruler pass
but Magnus doesn't go form
the main line or any other known line he
went d 4 which is really uncommon like
captured and castles yeah this is really
a very uncommon line it could just pose
into something which is known black now
went a six and if white would have
played Bishop a for now then we would
have transposed to a quite rare Spanish
sideline like going but should be seven
and yeah e5 and so on but he didn't do
this on a six he he simply captured on
c6 he takes and night eggs yeah and this
is some some wood weird kind of exchange
rule Oh personal with like having a
knight on f6 and white already has
castled Bishop c5 logical move attacking
the the night and he protected it of
course some black cannot really take on
you for because of the spinning move
yeah something like this loses a piece
so um black went castles here f3
protecting this now for good yeah it's
all pretty logical like trying to use
the weakened light square cm with a
snide he covered it and it's a very
standard kind of moves king h1 to get
out of this potentially dangerous
diagonal trip to d6 rookie 1c5 young you
want to get rid of this night and of
course why doesn't want to play a
passive move here so he wents forward
night at five and black needs to
this of course and now attacks the pawn
so what now very aggressive play now f
for pushing the night back ng for
securing the f5 pawn okay he didn't have
much choice I guess otherwise the pawn
would be lost but it's quite interesting
to see that white now tries to maybe
play on the G file opening it up and
these pieces are not so great but still
black as fairly solid I mean I play e45
of like and this kind of this kind of
position wouldn't scare me so much of
course the opponent would scare me but
the position um see him still pretty
solid yeah night reform centralizing the
night white could grab here because of
young rugby 8 and now a black gets it
back and test this active rope here on
the second rank so no good to take on be
794 is much more logical anyway to
centralize the peace queen d3 returns
Queen B five maybe putting some pressure
also on b2 ng5 so a very complicated
fighting position here he grabbed why
took on f6 and black to Quincy three and
now we've got a really messy position um
what you need to look at all so as the
time kayaking down to about five minutes
the clock times relate him and not one
hundred percent accurate so they come
close some but it's not one hundred
percent accurate cards non
minutes 30 seconds so it really has got
quite quite much more time left which is
certainly useful in this kind of
complicated position he took on g7
Bishop takes Andrew pg1 attacking here
so really a fighting position king went
to age 8 getting out of the GFR very
understandable and now he grabbed b7
there were alternatives here but of
course this is very hard to evaluate
Nigeria trying to use the night for
instance move like here yeah yeah maybe
he didn't want to want this to to have
black protect b7 it's um very
complicated brooksy one maybe where does
the Queen go now if it goes here you
might have this idea this is actually
the idea of naija form to to get to a
position where this diagonal is open and
white might be able to play something
like this I think it's not winning but
it's very dangerous so 94 was a very
serious alternative but he decided to
get one porn back here and have material
equality again 96 Queen back yeah like
cannot take here because this is also
hanging
Knight takes f5 nice shot here wants to
get this back oops Bishop takes c5 here
wyd actually could have taken on f5 34
and now nitey form with the idea night
g5 yeah this is the computer line and
not it not at all easy to see the point
is if you go here White has the smooth
if white would take black has no
problems at all and it's even better but
the absolutely crazy computer tells me
that this is actually winning for white
with this line
White's winning what yeah okay I'm it's
it's it's a youth read this one and this
one yeah okay absolutely impossible to
see fun line so Magnus could have to
show this again because this is super
super crazy line he could have taken
here and played this because on Queenie
195 is winning out okay absolutely
impossible for a human to find I mean
this is even yeah even in a tournament
game with lots of time on the clock
close to impossible all right so going
let's go back to human chess why took on
c5 rope the eight taking the Queen and
so this is hanging I am so he took if
this one of this actually checkmate no
now I have this check made around
problem again I should have shown the
mate all right I need to fix this and be
back in a second oh no it's working
again fine really really weird okay so
back to the game you played rock the 8y
took her on the 8th was check rook takes
and 93 yeah with the idea maybe two to
go here if possible it's not not easily
done but this is a general idea and
queen of 60 let's take stock here after
very wild complications um it's three
pawns each share material equality and
it's not obvious that white really has
anything what is going for a mess has
got one about one minute more on the
clock and it's a bit more active with
Queen on d5 but it doesn't look really
threatening
so let's see what happens rook g5 taking
the night and not being afraid of the
back rank what would happen if black
gives a check here I'm not sure what he
played I played whoop dat okay if black
gives a check here you could actually
just to treat the bishop and still
detect this hmm yeah maybe this doesn't
really bring much positive him okay so
you prefer he went rookie aid Queen
takes a five rock d three so again we
arrived at an end game which looks
completely equal but why does a bit more
active here he's got the rook on the 7th
better King blacks king is still here
and he's got the F porn so I mean it
should be a draw right but well play
continues and we'll see that white has
some ways to make slight progress
alright so I gave some moves here
without any comentary white made a slide
slide to advance here the edge porn
better King and so on but black still is
fairly solid how to imagine that he
could actually lose this but let's see
what happens King yet look a seven look
here checking the pawn Bishop g7 us and
this little kind of moves yeah flag
takes now King e6 and rook fa checkmate
very nice so this little kind of kind of
threats they really must be unnerving
Bishop g7 cannot take rook back age six
and now white might try to get something
on the edge porn like rook here look
here and captured king of seven it's not
much happening really and now ki can
give this check here in this position he
was very very low on time in this
position he could have played Bishop f6
and this would have secured the draw
let's say here
and why dumb cannot really make progress
it just checks all along I'd if he goes
over here then I move like rook f6 just
wins the F pawn this Bishop we have six
some I guess he rejected I mean he was
super low on time maybe he rejected it
an account on this move but here King g6
is the saving louth and it's just
absolutely nothing rook Hanks need to
move it and this is just just a draw I
mean even a draw without the a porn very
easy one so Bishop f6 here would have
drawn but you played Roxy form King f5
and now the problem is how do you save
this pawn with and you don't you don't
get it back immediately like in the
other line one problem is White has got
Bishop b5 and now what what are you
doing yeah and now the final shot rook
takes f8 check and black resigned if you
go here it's not not this move because
it's a pin but you can play h 7 and this
pawn just promotes if like sacrifices
here and this kind of stuff then you
still got the upon and white just
promotes to a new queen yeah so why why
did wide win this game I mean of course
black committed a blunder yeah a huge
mistake was bishop with the rook c4 but
the thing is why it was keeping the
pressure all the time
he always tried little little things
which irritated black and he'd always
needed to be careful look at the clock x
1 1 minute and 30 seconds again 30
seconds and he always keep trying to to
harass Blake here and at the end he went
down to well two seconds and you don't
know if this is really the correct time
but black certainly was very low on time
and then he committed this mistake here
and this is completely understandable
it's not a lucky we know anything he
just done kept the pressure on all the
time and yeah at the end kayaking here
really am yeah couldn't stand this
pressure at the end okay some after the
second day with 10 rounds played cards
pneus leading this tournament with the
huge score with eight and a half out of
10 and this amounts to a rating
performance okay this is not a low-rated
tournament but because its rapid but his
performance is above 3000 so 3000
performance it's a really amazing
alright so thanks for watching and also
I have a look at this game he played
against mamedyarov which I have made a
separate video upon all right yeah I
guess let's talk tomorrow again about
this tournament when we have the third
and final day I think we can be a yeah
pretty sure that God's will win this
thing with one and a half points ahead
but still very interesting and a very
fighting chest to be expected yeah
thanks and talk to you tomorrow